foreign
are you as obsessed with Wednesday Adams
as we are well we've got an intricate
breakdown of every location and design
aspect that made the show as bingeable
as it was and yes we're gonna be getting
handsy but more on that later I could do
this all day number one everyone's
favorite dismembered hand we were losing
it when we found out how thing was
really brought to life thing was
completely practical he was played by an
actor and magician named Victor Victor
was completely wrapped in a blue
bodysuit and the only visible part of
him was obviously his hand he was often
wheeled alongside Jenna Ortega on a
camera Dolly hiding the rest of his body
underneath tables behind corners and
many times behind Jenna herself and
don't worry we've got more on Jenna soon
we've praised her for her ability to
convey emotion without expression but
we've gotta give props to Victor for
conveying so much with just his hand
it's a really hard process because you
have to show emotion through a simple
hand that doesn't have a voice or
subtitles it's a lot of hard work to
show emotion through a hand I know a lot
of people won't understand but after
they see the season they will get it
number two did you notice how Wednesday
always stands out even when she's only
in black and white looks like a rainbow
vomited on your side that was a lot more
difficult to coordinate than you would
think take a look at the extras in the
background you'll never see them
sporting black and white please excuse
Wednesday she's alert you to color if
you take a look at Nevermore Academy and
compare it to the town of Jericho which
was built from the ground up by the
production team more on that later you
can see that color tactic popping up
again in Jericho everything is bright
and colorful you won't spot anything
colored black except of course Wednesday
Adams number three your typical New
England Town built specifically for the
show one of The Inspirations behind the
look of this town was Vermont which was
actually a lot more of a challenge to
capture than the crew had imagined also
fun fact did you know that the stores or
rather the facades of stores were based
on Charles Adams original illustrations
there are so many little ways the show
pays homage to its predecessor the
production team also brought on
architecture and sculpting students from
Bucharest to bring the town to fruition
there was very little CGI used in the
creation of Jericho production designer
Mark Scruton had a field day setting up
this town being able to design worlds
from scratch is what makes my job so
rewarding but being able to do it for
Tim Burton is a gift number four the
Gargoyles are more than an addition of
Gothic architecture did you notice that
the Gargoyles all show different
emotions they might also hold a clue to
the show's big mystery let us know in
the comments if you spotted it not only
that but the Gargoyles also represent
the different supernatural creatures
that attend the school even the archways
were designed to look like demonic faces
welcome to the corn it's a Pokemon
number five one of the most unique
aspects of the show is where it was
filmed you won't see a lot of media take
place in Romania all eight episodes of
the show were shot across 70 sets across
six sound stages and several locations
throughout Bucharest Romania one of the
major locations used for the Nevermore
exterior and aerial shots was kanta
kuzino Castle Mark scrutin envisioned a
New England Gothic mansion as the
setting for The Eccentric school special
effects were used to build on top of the
roof to give it more of that classic
Adams Family Vibe if you were to see
this castle in real life you'd realize
that it looks a lot more inviting and
way less spooky than it does on
Wednesday
magical place
number six let's take a look inside
principal weem's office I did send a
photograph of myself in my office to my
agent and said is this what your office
looks like this amazing set is actually
a historic house and Monument built in
1874 that's utilized for principal
weem's office and the mezzanine right
outside it's located on Victory Avenue
right in the heart of downtown Bucharest
did you spot the bear in the very back
of her office that's an Easter egg we're
gonna get into a bit later I know the
suspense is killing you number seven
let's get more into Nevermore this
stunning Castle is another Historic
Landmark in Bucharest the style is
French neo-gothic and was designed and
built between 1911 and 1923. some of its
most telling features are the alluring
staircase the stained glass windows the
surrounding handrails columns and its
bright red brick exterior number eight a
lot was built from scratch at Buffet
Studios we're talking about the entire
town of Jericho Pilgrim world the
sheriff's house and the quad it makes
sense they would do so much there as its
eastern Europe's largest and longest
film studio that's been active in cinema
for over 60 years they do everything
from Construction Services to props
wardrobe and post-production number nine
also known as The Gates mansion this set
can be described as a very very old
house out in the countryside the
production team did an entire rework of
the house to make it Wednesday
appropriate we did extensive work to it
including building the double garage a
new entrance and driveway with the iron
gates and breaking down the whole
interior to give it the correct
abandoned house look number 10. there
are so many hidden references in the
series which ones were you able to pick
up on did you notice the back wall in
the Weathervane Cafe there are a bunch
of metal weather veins screwed to the
wall they were designed to reference Tim
Burton's other movies Tim was always our
first choice for the series Wednesday or
that the stuffed bear in principal
weem's office is a nod to the stuffed
bear in The Adams Family House in the
original show from the 1960s what about
the music did you notice the use of the
harpsichord throughout the show that's
another nod to the music from the
original Addams Family TV show number
11. wear the black cats took their
well-deserved victory for the record I
don't believe I'm better than everyone
else just that I'm better than you this
iconic competition was filmed across two
lakes in Romania we're going to State
the obvious Wednesday is chock full of
Edgar Allan Poe references from this
Lake competition to the Raven dance the
story behind the PO cup not only the
fact it was filmed in the lakes that are
called some of Romania's Hidden
Treasures but that it's an actual
tradition dating back 125 years and
named for nevermore's most famous alumni
we couldn't think of a better setting
for this competition to take place
number 12. there are so many little
details in every costume did you notice
principal weem's costume was influenced
by Tippy Hedren's look as Melanie in
Alfred Hitchcock's the birds when it
came to the way everyone looked in
costume not one detail was too small
there's a lot to be said about every
costume piece but according to the
designer Colleen Atwood who is Tim
Burton's longtime collaborator her
approach was to Simply modernize The
Adams Family but still bring us that
hint of nostalgia with Wednesday we can
nail the iconic look right away with a
nod to the original pointed collar
little print dress and modernized
platform shoes and then put her in an
environment that she totally contrasts
with an American Happy Time public
school then you've given the nod to all
that's come before I wish you luck
we were definitely impressed with the
attention to detail and incredible lack
of CGI when it came to Wednesday what
did you think about the set design and
all the little details we definitely
missed our first time around give us
your thoughts in the comments
you're gonna see besides of her in this
series that you've never seen before are
you ready to find out everything we know
about Wednesday Adams like did you know
Tim Burton hand-picked the entire cast
or that Jenna Ortega performed her own
stunts and got to work with the OG
Wednesday Christina Ricci and now the
suspense is killing you number one how
many times did you see Wednesday blink
there are little Wednesday mannerisms
sprinkled throughout Jenna's performance
that only super Keen eyes would be able
to see it's funny I think my posture has
improved immensely since working on that
job her posture was always perfect and
her arms and hands stay pretty
stationary most of the time at some
point during the first couple weeks of
shooting I did a take where I did not
blink at all Tim Burton loved that take
so he and Jenna decided that it would be
one of Wednesday's weird mannerisms she
didn't even know she was doing it half
the time it just sort of happened every
time she would reset for a take I would
drop all the muscles in my face and Tim
really liked the Kubrick stare where I
stared through my eyebrows number two
Jenna was in a non Stop Cycle of work
for eight months straight we're talking
a minimum of 12 hour work days I would
wake up around 4 30 I'd be picked up
around 5 20 ish by 6 a.m she's in
wardrobe by 6 30 she's inherent makeup
and by 8 AM she's on set you would do
12-hour days we would have rolling
lunches so we just eat when we could
then in the evening by around six
o'clock she's in stunt rehearsal because
on top of all this she's doing her own
stunts and fight sequences more on this
later and then I might have a cello
lesson and then I go home that was my
day that was my life for eight months in
Romania number three the shoot days were
extra long for a reason Tim Burton and
Jenna Ortega wanted to do as many
different takes as possible to really
nail down Wednesday's characterization
for every single scene and every single
one of these takes were on camera we're
hoping to see an extended edition with
all the bloopers looking at you Tim
number four her hair was one of the most
important factors everyone knows
Wednesday Adams as the girl with the
signature long dark braids but it was
important to Tim Burton to establish
some sort of difference between who she
was then and who she is now they did a
lot of experimentation with different
wigs and clips but in the end Jenna
Ortega being as dedicated as she is
offered up something invaluable I said
hi maybe maybe just cut my actual hair
she was and they did and then he loved
it and that was something that that we
married and we stuck to number five
there's major sword fighting and fencing
going on in this show one of the things
that makes Jenna Ortega so incredible is
the dedication she gives to her work she
spent so many hours training to perfect
her fencing and sword fighting skills so
she could perform her own stunts there's
really important physical aspects like
that like the fencing that I knew that I
wanted to do myself and and have
ownership of number six 20 minutes of
winging it the audition process was over
Zoom as Jenna was in New Zealand filming
X she hadn't slept in 24 hours and
described her audition process as being
tired enough to wing it the audition
only took 20 minutes soon after she had
to pack up and move to Romania for eight
months when you approached with a
character like this and a director like
this and a story like this it's very
compelling you don't know when you're
going to get the opportunity to do
something like that again I knew that I
just had to take it number seven every
single detail was intentional when
creating Wednesday's look no detail was
too small the show's creators had a lot
to say about her look everything about
her look was intentional Wednesday's
shoes for example our next level every
teenage girl in the world is going to
have serious shoe Envy once they see
them when you first see Wednesday she's
in her iconic white collared black dress
outfit but then as The Show Goes On Her
Style evolves they always wanted her to
stand out from the crowd in some way
number eight one of the most important
factors of the show's look Romania is
not a location that you'll often see in
the media so capturing that grandiose
Eastern European Vibe was a huge
inspiration for both the cast and crew I
did send a photograph of myself in my
office to my agent and said is this what
your office looks like number nine there
are a lot of subtleties to Jenna
Ortega's performance Wednesday somebody
that I always was compared to my entire
life though the showrunners found her to
be a perfect fit for the character she
was nervous to portray her because she
wanted so badly to do the character
Justice I went to fencing lessons twice
a week
I went to cello lessons twice a week
everywhere she went she would walk like
Wednesday she thought people would think
she was insane with how much she was
putting into nailing down the character
I wanted her to be specific and certain
and assertive number 10. Tim Burton had
a very specific vision for Wednesday
according to Jenna he was one of the
most detail-oriented directors she'd
ever worked with the thing that makes
Tim a great visual director is that he
has an amazing sense of color and style
he liked to have a say in how every shot
was framed and even the type of lens
used on the camera because he kind of
liked when they were wide and a bit
disoriented he designed and brought to
life every single character with
sketches goth comes to him very
naturally and Tim designed what the
Monster looks like in the show number 11
what kind of show would this be without
the appearance of the original Wednesday
Addams Christina Ricci joins the cast as
Marilyn Thornhill a teacher at Nevermore
Academy it is scary it's a lot of
pressure and you you want to do justice
to someone like her you would think that
Jenna and Christina would be having some
pretty intense conversations about the
character they've both portrayed right
the strange thing is we never talked
about her being Wednesday once there was
only one time on the last day of
shooting that Jenna made a reference to
Christina's version of Wednesday they
both had an understanding and an
acceptance that their versions were
going to be different number 12 did you
know Jenna always wanted to star in a
silent film it is a hard day to play
with an expressionless character the
origin of most of Wednesday's mannerisms
and movements came from the idea of it
being shot like a silent film I felt
like that really encouraged mannerisms
or kind of balance the aspects of
surrealism and realism in the film Tim
Burton really connected with the idea as
well given the fact that the way Jenna
conveyed emotion most of the time was
silently through her Expressions because
they can be very
theatrical and dramatic and intense and
that is what Adam's family is number 13
Wednesday was originally a Latina
character in The Addams Family Comics
one of the most important parts of this
role for Jenna Ortega was getting to
represent Wednesday as a Latina because
it has never been done before anytime
that I have an opportunity to represent
my community I want that to be seen
another way Tim Burton wanted to make
this known was by exemplifying the fact
that the Adams Family participates in
Dia de los Muertos I was just in the
living room more seating for a year-long
Dia de los Muertos number 14 the entire
town was built from the ground up
coupled with the extraordinary setting
of Romania the set of the show was like
a character in itself Gwendolyn Christie
talks about her experience at New York
Comic-Con what I loved was that we
filmed in Romania so you have Landscapes
that had not been seen before it's
almost like looking at things with quite
a fresh pair of eyes on an epic scale
and much of what you see is real this
team really went all out they built a
town and used locations and there's an
awful lot of authenticity to bring that
very specific culture to life number 15
can you imagine getting an email from
Tim Burton Jenna was busy filming the
horror movie X as conversations about
Wednesday started to come up at Netflix
Tim Burton was the one who thought about
her for the role as he was a fan of her
work so he sent her an email asking if
they could meet I kind of felt like I
was being pranked or something naturally
everyone fell in love with her
performance right away because I'm very
dry and I don't think people can tell
when I'm being serious or when I'm being
sarcastic with me and a couple other
guys crawling around on the floor
growling at each other that was weird I
will never forget that are you curious
about how all the effects were done in
Wednesday well we've got some secrets to
spill about thing Nevermore Academy and
all of the featured creatures
hello thing number one everyone's
favorite hand is actually attached to a
full-grown man the extremely discreet
and talented Victor dorobantu wears a
full-bodied blue suit to create the
effect of the amputated hand his scenes
involved him twisting and contorting
into hard to reach places often times
crawling on the ground and hiding behind
Jenna Ortega sometimes he would have the
luxury of getting wheeled alongside her
on a camera Dolly check out the way this
underwater scene was filmed fun fact
Victor dorobantu and Christopher Hart
the actor who played thing in the 90s
are both magicians apparently it was
very important for the character of
thing to have dexterity which was one of
the main reasons Victor was cast
surrender
number two remember when she dropped
piranhas in the pool yeah they had to do
a little bit of special effects on the
roof of the school to make it a little
less Normy the school is called
polytechnica University of Bucharest and
it was founded in 1818 the swimming pool
though is filmed at a sports park in a
completely different location in
Bucharest
I'm not sure whose Twisted idea it was
to put hundreds of adolescents in
underfunded schools number three this
would be the monster that Wednesday is
desperate to find the identity of the
Hide was crafted completely with CGI to
achieve that bulging-eyed razor-sharped
tooth and massive Hawking monster
antagonist created by Tim Burton he was
based on a drawing that Tim Burton
designed before shooting even started he
brought a few drawings to the writer's
room and the writers all
enthusiastically agreed on the Hyde
drawing what really went on behind the
scenes while shooting was a lot
different than what we saw on screen the
hide consisted of a man in a full-bodied
black suit with tracking marks all over
it propped up on stilts with crutches
attached to his arms to portray the
massive size of the monster in real time
seeing the much less frightening costume
that Jenna Ortega really had to react to
we're even more impressed by her
performance number four obviously Oliver
Watson isn't a real merman but he's an
excellent swimmer what really went down
in this scene was half practical and
half special effects Oliver Watson
really did swim underwater but instead
of a full-length mermaid tale he just
had on a regular flipper to assist him
in the water as you can see from that
behind the scenes clip he's extremely
comfortable in the water and was
definitely the right choice to
accomplish Bianca in her pokeup scheme
you can even see his mermaid contacts as
he does a short video with the cast
thanks
number five also known as kanta kuzino
Castle this stunning Romanian Castle got
a spooky makeover to play the role of
Nevermore Academy the castle is actually
pretty inviting when looking at the
exteriors and the bright red roof but
the creators of the show thought the
roof didn't quite match that kooky Adams
Family Vibe so they built on top of it
with special effects you will love
Nevermore
of course you will number six remember
that time Wednesday was almost ended
like 10 minutes after she stepped on
campus though the scene was definitely a
lot safer behind the scenes it really
wasn't all that safe Jenna Ortega's
stunt double Jenny Ayumi was really
under the gargoyle and it really did
crash down but with little intermission
in between the gargoyle drops down
attached to a wire the stunt takes place
when she is shoved out of the way
number seven Rowan was definitely
binging stranger things before this in
the scene where he slams Wednesday up
against a tree he gets help from a few
wires behind the scenes and luckily
Jenna Ortega gets a nice mat to soften
the impact they practiced this stunt
with her stunt double beforehand to make
sure it was safe enough for her to
perform I give stunt coordinators such
immense anxiety Jenna was extremely
adamant about doing as many stunts as
she could I will throw myself on the
floor off a wall number eight though
you'd think after two hits were take
taken on Wednesday's life she'd want an
hour or two of therapy but clearly she
has better things to do Jenny Ayumi
fearlessly hops down from the rooftop
and makes sliding down the side of a
building on a wire look easier than it
possibly ever should number nine no
wires just Talent the intense fencing
battle between Wednesday and Bianca was
a stellar introduction to their complex
friendship you must be the
self-appointed queen bee interesting
thing about bees pull out their stingers
and they drop dead okay the word
friendship might be an overstatement but
regardless we get an incredible stunt
sequence out of this classmate conflict
your face finally got that splash of
color it's so desperately needed number
10 some of it was out of Lake and some
of it wasn't the PO cup was filmed
across two lakes in Romania but there
was also a set built at Buffet Studios
there were even some pretty hilarious
mishaps that happened while shooting
causing the entire cast to need a major
wardrobe change this is what could have
happened if thing hadn't saved the day
by decking Kent in the face
[Music]
number 11. we're talking about
werewolves of course when Enid gets a
visit from her parents she stares in
Envy at the pack she so desperately
wants to be part of we can't really
blame her though these guys can actually
catch frisbees in their mouths that's
pretty impressive the only thing they
really needed assistance with was
getting high enough in the air nothing a
simple trampoline can't fix otherwise a
completely practical stunt number 12.
the quad Goes Up in Flames in the finale
crackstone wasted no time after being
resurrected from the grave
in the show the fire starts off from
this massive explosion courtesy of crack
Stone's magic but behind the scenes it's
much calmer it's clear that the
production crew wanted a safe
explosionless set so CGI definitely came
in handy for that we also get to see
Bianca's incredible wire stunt where she
stands up to crack Stone talk about a
character Arc number 13 poor mayor Noble
Walker the mayor ends up getting hit by
a car sending Wednesday's investigation
in a whole new Direction in the show you
can't even tell that this was a
professionally performed stunt it looks
like he actually gets hit but if you
watch the behind the scenes footage
close enough you can fully see the
little jump onto the hood of the car
causing for a safe performance who did
you think it was behind the wheel when
you saw the first episode blue Cadillac
with no license plates yeah I know
number 14 you'd be surprised how minimal
the CGI was to build the town of Jericho
just little enhancements here and there
to breathe more life into the town it
was impressively built from scratch at
the famous Buffet Studios Eastern
Europe's largest Film Studio it was
supposed to look like a typical New
England town you can see they didn't
spare any details really honing on the
church steeple as it plays a huge role
in the big explosion scene all of the
other stores and shops the florist shop
cobbler shop and thrift store were
actually facades based on Charles Adams
original illustrations number 15 don't
worry we're pretty sure they had faces
behind the scenes these faceless
characters definitely add a touch of
never more spookiness that's so subtle
they're almost easy to miss the way they
achieved this faceless look was by using
a planner tracker to track the actors
faces and facial movements they then
used editing software to remove their
eyes and mouths isolating those images
and placing them onto the facial data
saved for the planner tracker and what
did you think about Wednesday CGI and
special effects it's pretty incredible
how many things were completely
practical from The Sword fights the
major stunts the PO cup and of course
thing what part of the movie Magic was
your favorite
I loved fencing I took to it almost
immediately which stunned from the first
season of Wednesday left you wondering
how they did it and did you know that
Jenna Ortega did many of her own stunts
herself let's dive in I was literally in
the stunt gym every morning when I
wasn't filming for seven months number
one where did you learn how to claw like
a werewolf at werewolf boot camp of
course Emma Myers has a fairly athletic
background as it is being not only a
dancer but a figure skater and a gymnast
as well and for her role as Wednesday's
roommate Enid she had to spend every
morning that she wasn't filming training
in a stunt gym for about seven months
with one session even lasting as long as
four hours me
a couple other guys
going around on the floor growling
it sounds to us that Emma might have
gotten a taste of how the actor playing
thing felt crawling on the floor don't
worry we'll get to that soon that was
weird I'll never forget that number two
there was plenty of flying about on
harnesses on this set most of the aerial
stunts were performed by trained stunt
actors like Jenny Ayumi umhau for the
scene where Rowan throws Wednesday back
into a tree Jenny was jerked back on
ropes following a count of three two one
go
a soft pad was tied around the trunk for
safety but Jenny still had to perform
this stunt multiple times and once
Callum Ross stepped out of frame Jenny
would then be dropped to the ground
number three to portray the hide stunt
performer Daniel him shoot had to act on
stalks and crutches when discussing the
difference between a stunt performer and
a stuntman Daniel said that a lot of it
really boils down to a physical theater
sort of physical acting ability and he
would know Daniel also served as stunt
double for Garrett Gates during his
fight scenes which he described as being
uncomfortable considering he was
standing under a heavy rain rig in the
Romanian winter number four would you
have guessed thing was performed by a
real actor Tim Burton insisted on
finding someone who could play the part
and so they brought in magician Victor
dorobantu who was surprisingly skilled
in contorting himself into uncomfortable
positions wearing a full VFX suit it's
pretty hard to find
that can express feelings Victor had to
work closely with the VFX team to make
sure that his whole body could easily be
edited out of the final product and at
one point he even had to perform
underwater number five the entire cast
had to learn how to canoe behind the
scenes videos show that it wasn't an
easy process either as the boat can be
seen capsizing and drink the water Joy
Sunday recalls having to wake up as
early as 5 30 to train with a team of 20
stunt people she said that racing
against each other was grueling before
going on to describe how her boat sunk
in cold water on the second day of
filming stating I'm also not the best
swimmer my body just like froze up but I
was also laughing it was hysterical the
whole time number six think you could
catch frisbee like a werewolf to do this
stunt actor Maxim kulong had to jump on
a trampoline to catch a frisbee mid-air
between his teeth before performing an
aerial role and landing on safety mats
provided for him during rehearsals but
on the actual day of filming the only
thing he'd have to land on would be the
grass Maxime also served as the stunt
double for Callum Ross and behind the
scenes videos show him laughing through
everything number 7. Jenna Ortega is a
perfect fit for the daring Wednesday
Addams she's become known for doing as
many of her own stunts as possible
having once told wired I give stunt
coordinators such immense anxiety Jenna
spent roughly two months training in
fencing before filming even began and by
the end of it she'd gotten so good that
her fencing teacher apparently told her
she could have had a future in the
Olympics not to brag though I'm not
saying I'm this great fencer but I kind
of am Number Eight you might recognize
Jenny as well Wednesday's stunt double
this South African dancer stuntwoman and
former Cirque du Soleil artist stepped
in for Jenna Ortega on some of her more
gravity-defying stunts and she
apparently had a great time while on set
describing herself as grateful for the
experience one behind the scenes video
shows Jenny scaling a drain pipe on
wires wearing a smile that looks a
little strange on Wednesday but maybe
she's only smiling because she's
performing death-defying stunts number
9. Jenna Ortega wasn't the only one who
had to learn how to fence Joy Sunday
began her training roughly one month
before filming she worked with a
Romanian instructor who she described as
being very intense at first but she said
that he really softened up especially
because I really got into it and enjoyed
it he was so passionate about it so I
took it immediately for her more
dangerous stunts stuntwoman Phaedra
sindel stepped in who Sunday has
actually worked with before she was her
stunt double on Sunday's first ever TV
job number 10. Brett Chan served as the
stunt coordinator for Wednesday he's
best known for the way that he
choreographs fight scenes explaining his
process by saying I take into play the
character stature like how big someone
is how thin someone is and what they use
then you take their characters and their
temperament this approach makes him the
perfect person to choreograph stunts
like Wednesday's fight scene in the
diner where Wednesday uses her calm and
collected temperament and smaller
stature to her benefit against bigger
aggressive bullies did you know TV teens
are rarely played by actual teenagers
Jenna Ortega's gloomy Wednesday Adams is
supposed to be 16 but Jenna was born
September 27 2002. she celebrated her
19th birthday shortly after the first
season began filming in the Autumn of
2021 birthday yes happy never if you
found yourself fooled by her short
stature that's because she's barely five
foot one meanwhile the actor who plays
Wednesday's Crush from the nearby town
of Jericho was considerably older Hunter
Duhan plays Tyler been he's supposed to
be a teen around the same age as
Wednesday but IRL the actor turned 28
during filming he may be older but the
actor turned bestie is not Emma Myers
plays the overly enthusiastic team
werewolf Enid Sinclair Enid is 16 the
same age as Wednesday but Emma was 19
during filming she's just a few months
older than Jenna she's also a similar
height which helps her look young and
speaking of Joy Sunday plays the queen
siren of Nevermore Academy Bianco
Barclay Wednesday's rival is also 16 but
joy is older than her co-stars she
turned 27 the month after filming
wrapped in Spring 2022. Bianca's
on-again off-again artsy boyfriend
Xavier Thorpe is played by Percy Hines
at the start of filming Percy was just
19. one month into shooting he turned
20. he fits right in with Jenna and Emma
here's one that might surprise you Musa
Mustafa plays Eugene odinger nevermore's
resident bee lover his character is
roughly 16 to too but Musa is just 13.
we don't know his exact birthday but
it's safe to say he was 12 when he shot
the first season back to some normalcy
Georgie farmer is Ajax a 16 year old
Gorgon Georgie was 19 during filming
just like Emma and Jenna his age is
probably not super surprising but the
actor's British accent might be you
think you got it figured out but then
it'll just switch on its head so
suddenly another British actor Naomi J
Ogawa plays Yoko Tanaka Naomi turned 22
right before filming began and since
then she celebrated her 23rd birthday
but enough about the students the
legendary Christina Ricci plays Miss
Thornhill Wednesday's dorm mom and
botany teacher if the actress looked
familiar it might be because you've seen
her as Wednesday in the 90s Adams Family
movies Wednesday Adams Christina played
the role between the ages of 10 and 12.
Miss Thornhill on the other hand is
supposed to be in her early 40s well so
is Christina she was 41 during filming
Game of Thrones Star by bundle and
Christie plays principal Weems the
character is morticia's old Nevermore
roommate and both characters are
supposed to be around 49 and 50. IRL she
was only 42 when Wednesday began filming
in September 2021. Oscar winner
Catherine Zeta Jones is the latest
actress to tackle the role of Morticia
and she's close to her character's age
Morticia is supposed to be around 50 and
Catherine turned 52 at the beginning of
shooting her birthday is just two days
after Jenna's meanwhile Luis Guzman
played the husband of Morticia Gomez
Adams like principal Weems and his wife
he's supposed to be 49 or 50 but he has
the biggest age gap between character
and actor Luis was 65 during filming
he's a full 13 years older than his
on-screen wife hello thing
are you as into Wednesday's severed
companion thing as we are we are
absolutely obsessed with Victor
dorobansu's stellar and completely
practical performance did you know they
had to make holes in the floor sometimes
to hide him thing is a classic character
in The Addams Family Canon number one it
was important to camouflage the rest of
him thing was played by magician Victor
dorobansu they specifically wanted a
magician for the role but more on that
later the first phone call I had with
with Tim he wanted thing to be derived
from an actor a performer Victor was
covered head to toe in a blue suit and
was often hidden behind Corners
underneath objects and most often behind
Jenna Ortega while filming actual
filming process was um just like working
with another actor he even had the
luxury of being wheeled on a camera
Dolly alongside her number two remember
when thing helped Enid and Wednesday win
the Poke up he played a major part in
their Victory by decking Kent in the
face before he could destroy their boat
there were no special effects involved
just Victor underwater holding his
breath and posing for the camera check
out how the scene was shot it's pretty
impressive how he managed to do so many
takes underwater without coming up for
air action reset and action
one more quick number three not like
anything we've mentioned so far would be
considered easy oh yeah paint out it's
easy but we're like painting out 90 of
the human being that's dominating the
shot keeping the rest of him the hand is
actually a major challenge it's a slow
setup as they have to make sure the set
is lit well enough so that Victor isn't
casting any Shadows or anything that
could take away from thing looking like
anything other than a severed hand
number four yes hours for one hand the
prosthetic and makeup application that
Victor had to endure was no easy feat
the makeup artist spent hours applying
the stitching blending and coloring in
the subtle purple tones that could
easily be overlooked and we both know
how vain you are number five Jenna
Ortega describes the filming process as
working with a regular actor you're um
reacting and he's speaking he's signing
Victor had to develop the particular way
that thing would essentially speak to
the other characters it's pretty hard to
find movements that can express feelings
Jenna had no issue at all talking to a
hand with Janna she accepted it really
quickly that she's talking to a hand the
only part she struggled with was when
she had to pretend he was there when he
really wasn't did you really think my
highly trained old factory sense
wouldn't pick up on the faint whiff of
Neroli and Bergamot in your favorite
hand lotion number six they specifically
needed a magician's hand for the role in
the 90s thing was played by a fellow
magician Christopher Hart they wanted to
continue with that type of casting for
Wednesday somebody who had the right
look to the hands who had Nimble fingers
was able to do all of these moves
naturally a magician would be the right
choice for the role also they had to be
you know young enough and supple enough
to fit in very awkward situations number
seven a lot had to be done to
accommodate the rest of Victor's body we
mentioned before how he had to be hidden
sometimes it wasn't so easy hey I can't
fit under a bed let's make a hole in the
floor if you think that sounds excessive
let's raise the whole building in the
air so put him under the floor sometimes
when all else failed they had to break
out the CGI number eight this is where
it would get a bit tedious on set you
have to prepare with the VFX guys find
ways to hide the thing if you've seen
our other Wednesday videos you know how
long Jenna Ortega's work hours were this
was part of the reason for that every
single setup we did someone would have
to come in with a gray ball silver ball
chip chart this inevitably slowed things
down a lot there's a lot that goes into
doing it number nine the way thing
communicates with Wednesday was
premeditated by the
every day we'd show up and go ah that
looks right I feel like I kind of know
what he's saying I know I'm stubborn
single-minded and obsessive number 10
did you know this was Victor's first
acting credit Victor is a magician by
trade that's what he does that's how he
makes his living he's never been an
actor being on a set like this was all
super new to him it's be hard to create
from start to end when they first
brought him in for rehearsals everyone
was impressed by how quickly he nailed
the character particularly things
signature walk at first seen he kind of
really nailed
so what do you think about Victor dorbon
Sue's first on-screen performance after
being hidden underneath the floor
wheeled alongside Jenna and a dolly and
coming up with a unique language we're
impressed I actually felt really
insecure about this I choreographed that
myself and I think it's very obvious
that I'm not a dancer Wednesday's iconic
dance has all of the internet in a
Chokehold do you know the original story
behind it did you know that Jenna Ortega
was majorly sick when she filmed it or
that she pulled it together at the last
minute it was really awkward but only
because I make things awkward number one
did you know the original idea for the
dance was a flash mob can you imagine
Wednesday Adams in collaboration with
the entirety of Nevermore Academy on a
dance I break out into hives and then
the flesh peels off my bones Jenna
Ortega was actually the one to vouch for
Wednesday doing a dance on her own I
thought no there's no way Wednesday
would be cool dancing and encouraging a
bunch of people after she talked it over
with Tim Burton he agreed to let her do
her own thing that was really cool for
me number two Jenna wouldn't consider
herself a dancer much less a
choreographer she does like to have
ownership over physical aspects of her
characters and Tim Burton refused to
work with a dance choreographer so it
seemed more than appropriate for Jenna
to take the task on herself but how much
did she prepare we'll get into that in a
second after seeing everything she had
on her plate oh my God I was kicking
myself I felt like such a fool I was
like I'm not a dancer I don't do any of
that she has no experience in that field
at all what do you think would you have
known oh wow that's like a hidden talent
number three we wouldn't dare call Jenna
a procrastinator she was just super busy
I was doing cello that week fencing that
week I just didn't have time Tim Burton
comes up to Jenna in her trailer I know
you said that you wanted to choreograph
the self because ever this yourself
because I refuse to see choreographer
this was only two days before shooting
the scene he was like I know you got it
you've been working on it I'm not even
worried about it I trust you she in fact
hadn't been been working on it at all
and I said oh yeah you know it's all so
good and I had not gone over it at all
number four Jenna didn't sleep for two
days trying to figure it out she watched
a lot of videos of Susie and the
Banshees I like Lena Lovich I think
she's a weirdo and she had a lot of
really interesting music videos she even
found hours of archival footage of goth
kids dancing in clubs in the 80s it's
nice to kind of see them enjoy
themselves a little bit and I took some
of the stuff that they do and added it
towards the end just she was also really
inspired by Fosse I had seen some of his
films in the past so I took a little bit
of inspiration from him as well number
five we're not talking about Christina
Ricci who plays Marilyn Thornhill on the
show my name is
or Laurel Gates whatever you want to
call her she played Wednesday back in
the 90s the baby weighs 10 pounds The
Cannonball weighs 20 pounds which will
hit the stone walkway first we're going
all the way back to Lisa loring's
original Wednesday dance from the 60s
did you catch that classic inspiration
to dance well she'll think your boss
number six it was Jenna's first day with
kovid the day of the dance shoot so it
was awful to film and I asked to redo it
but we didn't have time she woke up that
day with major body aches and a sore
throat but she didn't know she had covet
until after because they were waiting on
test results I felt like a little Goblin
had been let loose in my throat and was
just scratching the walls of my
esophagus number seven there was
actually quite a bit of it we mentioned
before that a big inspiration behind
Jenna's moves was Susie and the Banshees
I feel kind of bad because I kind of I
ripped off a couple of her moves she
used a few of Susie's moves as
improvised filler in between some of her
other choreographed moves where she's
just going like this for a really long
time and she's just singing at the stand
or whatever and I did that as filler
those moves proved to be useful while
she was waiting for another move or a
camera movement because I just had to
throw stuff in there to kind of
improvise number eight that song was
picked by both Jenna Ortega and Tim
Burton Jenna read the script for episode
4 pretty early on but they didn't have
any idea what kind of dance they wanted
or even what song to play a week before
we shot the dance he um chose the song
gugumok by The Cramps Jenna actually was
pretty ahead of the game and made a
playlist with potential songs for the
dance number and the cramps is one of my
favorite bands ever so I was super
excited super pumped it was on my
episode 4 playlist oh somebody's gonna
get it she bad she's not kidding around
the cast of Wednesday has a lot to say
about the show do you know the backstory
behind Jenna Ortega's iconic dance
number or what about Christina ricci's
history with the character Wednesday
number one truly an iconic number
choreographed by Jenna Ortega herself
this is my favorite scene we brought
this up so many times this dance has
everyone on the internet in a Chokehold
it's inspired so many remakes Tick Tock
videos and even Lady Gaga had to hop
onto the trend the funny thing about
this though is Jenna wouldn't even
consider herself a dancer much less a
choreographer I choreographed that
myself and I think it's very obvious
that I'm not a dancer not one single
person agrees with you Jenna oh my God
man I can I could watch an entire show
of just this did you also catch the
reference to Wednesday's original dance
number number two there would have been
a riot if we lost thing like this would
be the most emotional moment
this is the only scene where we actually
see Wednesday express some pretty
intense emotions though Jenna Ortega
found it to be a bit campy behind the
scenes No in a campy which I appreciate
considering Jenna is actively making a
name for herself in the horror scene she
starred in the movie X scream and the
babysitter part 2. it's no surprise that
this Wednesday sequence is one of the
campier horror scenes she's shot
throughout her career
[Music]
number three thing gets shocked back to
life promise that whoever did this to
you will suffer this was actually one of
the more Awkward scenes for Jenna to
shoot if you've seen our other Wednesday
videos you would know that some of the
most difficult scenes for her to get
through were the ones where she had to
hold or carry things
the reason why it was so awkward for her
was because of those types of scenes she
was usually playing pretend she didn't
always have something to hold or pick up
it's so outrageous number four everyone
loved Christina ricci's performance here
please don't make this more difficult
than what already is married
everyone in the cast thought Christina
was the perfect person to play the
Sinister villain in the end mostly given
the fact that no one would ever suspect
her Christina with all of her
Charisma and dynamic personality the
cast actually knew the secret before
even being handed the script but
obviously had to keep it tight Under
Wraps it makes it even more of a Twist
if you think about the fact that
Christina played the OG Wednesday back
in the 90s this is my costume I'm a
homicidal maniac they look just like
everyone else pretty wild number five
we've got some Stellar acting from a
blue man under a table also Victor
killed that was that really him dude
yeah that was Victor a blue man under
the table just going as most of you
probably already know Victor dorobansu
is the magician who plays Wednesday's
severed sidekick thing that's thing
see like your pet most of his job
description involves hiding under beds
tables and behind Jenna Ortega while
performing a scene we can imagine just
how much his body aches after the long
work days in Romania everyone enjoyed
filming this show Fred Armisen was
definitely feeling it that day and I was
like I just want to go home guys
come on number six Jenna Ortega knows
Wednesday would never cry over anyone
else it's also a really important moment
for Wednesday I think it's the only time
we really see her cry when talking about
Wednesday's love interests Jenna feels
strongly about Wednesday's aversion to
it I'm glad that it was over him though
I don't think it would have made sense
over anything else she thinks the
character couldn't really care less
about anyone except of course for a
thing I love the slime
if you die I will kill you and
eventually Enid she was happy to see her
relationships come full circle in the
end but more on that later number seven
one of Jenna Ortega's new found skills
we've done this on my 19th birthday
if I was in a storage fight like this I
would just be like you win Jenna learned
a lot of skills and worked incredibly
hard on camera as well as on her days
off in her spare time she learned to
fence speak German and Play The Cello
for the role there's so many pieces of
coverage and bits and also a fencing
classes
it was crucial to her that she was able
to do a lot of the physical aspects of
the show like the fencing there's really
important physical aspects like that
like the fencing that I knew that I
wanted to do myself and and have
ownership of number eight Jenna doesn't
take Wednesday's relationship slightly
Wednesday is very cold and closed off in
the beginning and you know how the way
that she's always been her reaction to
seeing the end of season one was mostly
in response to Wednesday's relationships
coming full circle I think for me just
that emotional aspect was the most
satisfying or most rewarding for me
particularly the Heartbreak of losing
principal Weems and the hug she and Enid
share at the end of the big Showdown
it's clear Wednesday has changed as a
character number nine we finally get to
see Enid wolf out in the final episode
Enid who has had severe performance
anxiety when it came to transforming
into a werewolf finally takes her true
form to fight the incredibly dangerous
hide I remember going into ADR and
seeing our final fight scene even when
it still had the stunt guys
heavily anticipated moment for the cast
and audience alike she was pivotal in
the success of Nevermore I texted you I
was like it's really cool
number 10 some of the actors favorite
parts of shooting were getting to watch
their co-stars act watching about you
guys do this was so fun a lot of this
cast would have serious fomo if they
missed a major scene or something they
thought was really good in the script
circling back to Wednesday's dance scene
everyone really wanted to be on set that
day to watch I hadn't seen we we hadn't
seen her do this yeah I know and can we
blame them number 11. did you know you
can watch Wednesday in nearly every
language even with your eyes closed you
can still tell which character is
speaking even if you don't know the
language
it's Poppy Gomez a lot of dooding yeah
yeah yeah there's no one more doting or
concerned than Wednesday's father and of
course you can always tell it's
Wednesday by the lack of emotional
inflection
Enid's voice is one of the most distinct
in the entire show Jenna has no problem
calling her out about it either if it
were you it'd be really obvious yeah
number 12 this is one of the first times
we see The Addams Family as part of a
regular Society we get to see Wednesday
front and center leading the show this
time when amazing for obvious reasons
The Adams Family has never fit in much
with the outside world because of their
notably creepy and kooky nature The
Adams Family always used to kind of
exist outside or on the periphery of
society they literally have a severed
hand as a family member we can't exactly
see things showing up for PTA meetings
or anything because of that The Adams
Family being so integrated as Wednesday
leads the narrative was one of the
cast's favorite aspects of the story so
it's fun to see them be a part of our
world especially because we've never
seen Wednesday as a teenager before only
as a child
Even after spending over eight months
filming the show the cast of Wednesday
still clearly enjoys watching their
co-stars most iconic scenes what was
your favorite moment the actors watched
any disagreements let us know down in
those comments